what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
we just got episode five of secret
Invasion the penultimate episode only
one episode left and right away let us
know your thoughts on this episode and
the entire Series so far in the comments
down below what do you think of it do
you like it do you not and why so now we
know what Graphics ultimate plan is and
we know why this is so personal to Nick
Fury you know besides having a scroll
wife a detail in which even Sonia
fallsworth didn't know and was really
surprised to hear her character is
Amazing by the way but more on her in a
bit now in the last episode we saw the
president get attacked and sadly we also
saw Talos died but a few other important
events happened in that episode that you
need to know going into this one one is
that Roadie is a scroll the scroll rava
is actually Roadie Now Kevin feige did
say that we are going to find out just
how long Roadie has been a scroll for
and this is quite a sensitive subject
right now for example the big question
is was a roadie in Avengers end game a
scroll was that rather has it been rava
pretending to be Roadie since the events
of Captain America Civil War where
Rhodey was injured some people think he
could have even died during the events
of Captain America Civil War but keep in
mind we do have the movie armor Wars
coming out and this is most likely going
to be about the actual Roadie not the
scroll pretending to be Roadie but
Roadie himself dealing with that
aftermath of rava pretending to be him
we do also know that President Ritson is
not going to be president for long
because in Captain America New World
Order Harrison Ford is going to be
playing Thunderbolt Ross and Thunderbolt
Ross is going to become the new
president of the United States now this
might happen because the world realizes
that scroll have been living among them
and when they find out that Roadie is
actually a scroll maybe president ritzen
steps down maybe he gets impeached maybe
he doesn't actually survive the end of
the series either way the aftermath of
this show is going to be felt in many
different MCU projects coming up Captain
America Brave New World the Thunderbolts
the Marvels and armor Wars those at the
minimum that and we now have super
scroll and as far as we know right now
there are only two gravic and Gaia and
we're still kind of unsure what powers
Gaia has because we haven't exactly seen
her use any she was even in a gunfight
scene in this episode and she just shot
the entire time no super scroll powers
used we know that she can heal because
of the extremists but we don't know if
she got any of the other powers as well
but Talos really did die in the last
episode and this episode starts off with
Nick Fury taking president ritzen to the
hospital he is unconscious but Fury is
trying to talk to him whispering in his
ear it wasn't the Russians do not trust
Roadie unfortunately he doesn't have the
clearance to go back with Roddy so he
simply takes a chair and sits in front
of the door so nobody else can get to
him specifically so Roadie who is really
Brava cannot get to him now as they take
president Ritz and back Fury turns
around looks at a TV which shows the
news
ukn24 not the first time we've seen them
in the MCU by by the way and he sees
that they're showing a picture of Talos
it's being broadcasted to the world that
aliens are among us not that it's really
that big of a surprise for the people of
Earth they've dealt with a lot not the
first time they would see aliens on
Earth it is however the first time that
they are publicly showing scroll and
this is an indicator that the aliens
have infiltrated Earth not simply a
visited but have hid among them and
infiltrated them now we go back to the
headquarters of the scroll they are
returning home after the attack we see
all of them get out of the car but Pagan
sits in the car for just a little bit
longer you can clearly tell that he's
frustrated and in the next scene he
addresses Fury and starts to say Fury
never trusted you and I'm questioning
whether we should as well he tells
gravic that he should be happy Talus is
finally dead however graphic is still
kind of pissed because Talos wasn't the
target it was the president the
president is supposed to be dead and
America is supposed to believe that the
Russians attacked and killed the
president they were supposed to start
World War III but they were unsuccessful
but graphic in his frustration says that
if Pagan would have done and stolen what
he told him to he could have taken them
out single-handedly and now we finally
know what he was trying to find he was
trying to find the DNA of the Avengers
at the end of the episode Nick Theory
explains to Sonia fallsworth that the
Harvest is nearly every Avengers spilled
blood in the Battle of Earth even Carol
Danvers so we know that this was the
battle that took place in Avengers
endgame it was the battle for Earth and
the universe in which of course the
Avengers won however Nick Fury revealed
that basically after the battle he
secretly without any type of government
knowing this sent in scroll to collect
those DNA samples and the leader of that
mission was gravic that's how graphic
knew about the blood samples of all the
Avengers and that's most likely where he
got the idea to create a super scroll
and since graphic knew about that that
is what he has been searching for ever
since he had rebelled against Nick Fury
now we know that he has the DNA samples
of Gru to call obsidian extremist a
frost beast and that makes him super
powerful however it doesn't make him
Unstoppable and that is what he was
telling Pagan he told him that if he
would have just stolen the vial with
their DNA in it I could have created a
super soldier out of myself with all of
the avengers's DNA all of their powers
and been the ultimate super being and
could basically be unstoppable but Pagan
couldn't find it and he tells graphic
that he couldn't find it because it
wasn't in any of the locations that
graphic told him so he doesn't think
Nick Fury trusted him to tell him where
it was and now he's thinking that he
can't trust him either and he's right
because he immediately dies at the hands
of graphic after he states that showing
us that graphic doesn't really care
about his people per se and we really
learned that in another scene where
gravic tells rava to essentially kill
the scroll population that is in Russia
their headquarters showing that he
really doesn't care and I actually have
the opportunity to interview Kingsley
benedir who plays gravic and he did
mention that his mission isn't exactly
for his people but it's more about kind
of
he's also doing this
for his people as well that's that was
my question coming up is is it seems
like that but is he blind now is it has
it become about it I think he needs the
people around him that that's what's
going on ah but I think what's operating
underneath
for the show needed to be very different
you know otherwise I feel like yeah I
think there needed to be multiple layers
going on
um love that yeah I don't think he
trusts anyone
so he kills Pagan and everybody sees it
of course and he tells them that he's
faceless you're all faceless you're
nameless basically telling them you
don't matter so who they thought was
their awesome leader who was doing all
of this for the sake of the scroll
trying to find them a new home Earth is
not actually what they thought he was
now in the comics Pagan actually played
a pretty big role in secret Invasion
Pagan was disguised as Elektra and she
kidnapped Echo who was about to have her
own Disney plus Series this year and she
was trying to brainwash Echo when Echo
snapped out of the brainwash and stabbed
her and killed her in which then she
reverted back to her scroll form just
like they do in this series when they
are killed but the big thing about this
was nobody had any idea that Elektra was
a scroll typically mutants like
Professor Xavier or Wolverine could
either read their minds or sense that
they were scroll this was the first
instance of them not being able to tell
that a scroll was disgued advised as
somebody that they knew this was a huge
moment of secret Invasion and if you
want to check out the entire comics for
secret Invasion be sure to check out my
buddies at comicbookdirect.com they have
created a website and company that makes
comic book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now overall this episode of
secret invasion moves pretty quickly and
we do find out a lot in this episode
Roadie or rava eventually does arrive at
the hospital and Nick Fury can't really
do anything about it the secret service
does not know know that Roadie is a
scroll and he can't exactly shoot the
scroll because then he'll be killed
himself by the Secret Service also at
the same time rava reveals that
basically in about 60 seconds the
footage of graphic disguised as Nick
Fury killing Maria Hill is going to hit
all of the news broadcasts TV the
internet newspapers it's gonna be
everywhere and Nick Fury is going to be
the most wanted person on the planet
also notice that rava continues to call
Nick Fury Nick and as they explained in
Prior episodes nobody calls him Nick but
at this point it is very intentional and
almost like a little jab at him then we
cut to what I believe is MI6 here Sonia
ballsworth goes up to Tony Curran's
character who was just simply labeled as
Derek who was most likely just her
Superior officer who she knows is indeed
a scroll and there's actually a really
cool comic book Black Widow moment here
before she comes in he is watching the
TV screen that indeed shows the footage
of graphic disguised as Nick Fury
killing Maria Hill and it says Nicholas
Fury wanted former Shield director Fury
sought from the the murder of agent
Maria Hill it then cuts to another video
of Talos in his half human half scroll
form that we saw him in in the last
episode and it states alien infiltration
suspected alien involvement and ambush
of U.S presidential Convoy but then
Sonya fallsworth comes in and he asks do
you really think scroll up infiltrated
and she's pretty much like yeah we both
know you're a scroll so let me go ahead
and shoot you and notice that she
actually shoots him through his hand and
his leg his hand was sitting on his leg
but I think she specifically was going
for the hand because she clearly didn't
want to kill him she simply wanted to
reveal the fact that he was a scroll in
which his hand does turn green revealing
to everybody else working around her
that he is a scroll and that she's not
just going off and shooting her Superior
for no reason whatsoever but this is
actually something that happens in the
comics when the Avengers and the X-Men
have to fight the scroll they have no
idea who is actually a scroll since the
scroll are taking the shape of the
Avengers and the X-Men so Black Widow
just decides to start shooting everybody
in the arm or the leg basically stating
that her eye idea is to shoot everybody
and depending on the color of their
blood they'll know if they're a skrull
or a human so this kind of seems like a
cool Black Widow comic reference R.I.P
in Sonia fallsworth really is something
the woman is efficient and wastes no
time and is one of the best characters
of the show in my personal opinion and
this shows us what the show has been
showing us the entire time the scroll
really have infiltrated governments
throughout the entire world we cut back
to the scroll headquarters and graphic
takes a call from rava rava basically
says hey I told the president what you
wanted me to tell them it was the
Russians and the scroll working together
and that they needed to bomb the scroll
headquarters in Russia now the president
realizes that this is going to start
World War III attacking the Russians and
Roadie or rava says it's better to have
World War III than to have an alien
invasion and basically you have to do
this Mr President but no decision has
been made at least on screen yet that we
have seen now just as the phone call is
ending graphics people attack him
because they're no longer behind graphic
because they do not believe that he is
doing anything for the sake of their
people the scroll he's simply doing
things out of Revenge they put a bag
over his head and attempts to suffocate
him and some of them suffer really bad
Fates like getting stabbed in the neck
with a knife they of course can't take
him down because he is indeed a super
scroll right now although he doesn't
really use any of his powers besides his
strength that he no doubt got from Cole
obsidian so he of course defeats the
mall and kills a few of them including
Beto he ends up slicing his throat in
front of a lot of people and this no
doubt will lead to the rest of the
scroll going against gravic and
hopefully will result in the rest of the
scroll actually going back to Nick
Fury's side we then go back to London
where we see the location that the
scroll we're in from episode 2 back in
1997. guy is there waiting for Fury and
they talk about the location of Brixton
and how after World War II Brixton
became a Haven for immigrants from the
West Indies and this is sort of a
correlation between the immigrants and
scroll being immigrants they are not
from Earth they have come from their own
planet scrollos and are essentially
immigrants on the planet looking for a
new home in which Fury of course
promised them he would find them one now
here's something that's really really
interesting Nick Fury tells Gaia that
Talos died and she cuts him off says
that's all she really needs to know and
what's interesting is that we did not
see a scene in last episode or this
episode that was shown to us in the
trailers and that is a scene of Gaia on
top of her father's dead body and from
what we've seen this was taking place
during the scene as he died not too long
after now this would explain how they
got his body because as far as we know
Nick Fury left with the president and
had to leave Talos there however we
don't really have any context whatsoever
as to why or how she was there but
knowing that this scene took place in
the trailer kind of tells us how she
managed to get talus's body in which she
tells Nick Fury I need to bury my
father's body so he sends her to his
wife Priscilla stating she'll know what
to do then we cut back to Sonya
fallsworth at the Daltons the two
doctors who were essentially creating
these super scroll machine for gravic
and again Sonja fallsworth is wasting no
more time anymore when the two of them
enter she simply says hello skrulls not
wasting any time not beating around the
bush simply calling them out and stating
tell us everything or we're gonna kill
you now they end up Burning Down The Lap
In which Victor Dalton takes his wife
hostage and says I'm not gonna let her
betray gravic showing his loyalty to
Graphics still but as we've learned from
the series you don't mess with Sonia
falseworth she instantly takes out her
gun and shoots him right in the head
Precision shot now Gaia takes her
father's body to Priscilla or Vara keep
in mind Gaia does know Vara it might
have been a really long time until they
last saw each other and they might not
know what each other look like in human
form but the second that Gaia says I'm
Gaia I need help Burying my father Fury
said you could help fire knows who she
is and of course Gaia knows who Bara is
because Fury told her Navarra ultimately
ends up helping Gaia bury her father
completing somewhat of a scroll ritual
for their dead and giving up an offering
which she decided to choose her mother's
ring who we also found out in the first
episode also died Bara starts to recite
some words that seem to be part of a
scroll burial ritual as we hear Talos
say the same words to some dead scroll
in the first Captain Marvel film now
ultimately we know that gravic sent
skrull to Priscilla's house to kill her
for betraying them Priscilla and Gaia
are talking about marriage and Gaia says
did you ever really get to be your true
self in which Priscilla or Vara take
great offense to that but this shows
right here how sensitive it is for
scroll to want to live in their own
forms but can't they can't show their
scroll they have to be disguised and
right as the conversation gets pretty
heated the soldiers come in Priscilla
and Gaia run but Priscilla is prepared
for this after all she is the wife of
the famous Infamous spy Nick Fury no
doubt she has precautions in play and so
does Nick Fury we broke down the scene
yesterday but both women seem to be
highly trained in combat as they both
pretty much turned into John Wick and
defeat the people that gravic sent to
kill them and this is all we see of them
in this episode but no doubt they'll
return in the next one in the meantime
graphic calls Fury and basically States
hey if you don't bring me the Harvest
America is essentially going to bomb
Russia and start World War III but if
you bring me the Harvest I won't do that
he also tells Fury to bring some iodide
pills because the reactor room can be
quite aggressive now iodide pills are
used to block certain types of radiation
no doubt that the machine gives off some
radiation and plus not to mention
they're at a nuclear plant just a very
interesting small detail here meanwhile
Nick Fury managed to get himself a plane
a private jet and once he gets on board
he is greeted by Rick Mason who we saw
in the Black Widow film a former Soldier
turned into International Smuggler
another cool Black Widow reference here
and he helps him get to Finland in which
we see some more Black Widow and Captain
America Winter Soldier references as
Nick Fury disguises himself with some
cloaking devices that we've seen before
in those two previous films now one
would think that they would use these
devices more often especially when you
are fighting scroll in fact when Nick
Fury gets in the car with Sonia
fallsworth she asks why the Widow's Veil
no doubt named after the black widows
couldn't actually cloak and change your
body it's a billions worth of technology
and research and development but Nick
Fury States that's the newer version not
this version the older version that he
has implying that there is a newer
version that can change your entire body
so it really makes you wonder why
they're not using this technology to
fight against the scroll since they
can't really tell who as a scroll is it
would be pretty advantageous if the
scroll couldn't actually tell which
human is who I wouldn't be surprised if
this comes into play in the final
episode true Mission Impossible style
but we'll have to wait and see on that
so in Finland fallsworth and fury drive
to Nick Fury's or I should say one of
Nick Fury's Graves on the way there she
explains what we've already talked about
how graphic wants the Harvest which is
the blood samples of a good majority of
all the superheroes she asks why he's
not calling in the Avengers and Nick
Fury explains that since he was the one
that had gravic and other scroll go
collect that DNA he feels directly
responsible and has to handle this one
on his own he also reveals to her that
he is married to a scroll and that's
another big reason why this is so
personal to him plus they can't get used
to calling in superheroes for everything
they have to be able to defend the Earth
themselves plus not to mention right now
there are a few less superheroes than
there were before Tony Stark is gone
Captain America is presumably gone or on
the Moon yes there are a lot of new
Heroes Rising but Nick Fury has been on
saber he hasn't been on Earth so he
probably hasn't been in contact with him
so basically he says this is on me this
is on Nick Fury and this scene is very
important he starts to get all of his
old stuff back the eye patch the leather
jacket some guns and basically the
significance of this scene is showing us
that the old Nick Fury is back the
entire season people have been talking
about how Nick Fury is not the same he's
old now he's washed up he's got some
PTSD from the blip and basically he's
lost his way he's not a threat anymore
he's not the old Nick Fury but now he's
back in a redeeming Arc for the final
episode he becomes who he once was who
he's always really been on the inside of
course and he grabbed grabs a sample in
which we are kind of assuming is the DNA
is the Harvest and is going to meet
gravic in the finale now we're not 100
sure that this is indeed the Harvest
would Nick Fury directly bring this to
graphic and give that to him so he could
become super powerful no but this is
Nick Fury perhaps there is another plan
to this perhaps this isn't the Harvest
but if it is he definitely has a plan
now we have seen a new scene that Marvel
released recently that does show Nick
Fury fighting graphic and graphic does
seemingly look like the Hulk now this
could be due to the fact that he does
end up getting the Harvest sample and
puts that in himself or this could be
due to his old powers that he first got
from becoming the super scroll the first
experiment this could be from the powers
of coal obsidian or the frost Beast
however he does look very hulk-like here
so perhaps he does get a little bit of
the Harvest in him perhaps Nick Fury
planned on this knowing that he probably
couldn't handle take it in the Harvest
perhaps Nick Fury thinks that it is
going to eventually kill him and in
doing so perhaps Nick Fury realizes that
that Dean a sample the Harvest needs to
be get rid of for sure and Nick Fury
should have never even got it in the
first place nevertheless there should be
a pretty epic fight in the finale next
week but go ahead and let us know all of
your theories in the comments down below
and of course let us know what you
thought about this episode don't forget
to like the video and subscribe and
leave a comment so you can enter a
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items we pick a winner at
the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item if you'd like to
further support the channel you can
check out our patreon account our
website and join our Discord server and
of course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf
thank you